Of all of the chemical
compounds-- and
there are many millions--
I think water has to be one
of the most amazing.
And it's one of my favourite.
What we're going to do today is
see how just a tiny amount
of water can cause an
enormous fire ball.
This is a giant safety screen.
A giant cylindrical safety
screen, as it will be, to
protect Peter from the effects
of pouring a small amount of
water into some burning, boiling
oil, which hopefully
will produce a giant
fire ball.
Thanks to the screen it will
go up, rather than out.
We're going to take you up to
the roof because no ordinary
room could contain the
fire ball that we
are hoping to produce.
As you may know, oil and
water just don't mix.
And I can show this.
So we'll put some water in here
and put some oil in here.
The oil molecules are really
actually quite large.
They contain a lot of hydrogen,
a lot of carbon
atoms, a bit of oxygen, and
maybe a few other elements.
But this is really quite
a large molecule.
The water?
Just three atoms--
which one's going to
come out on top?
The amazing thing is the
water is actually more
dense than the oil.
And this again is because of the
interactions between the
water molecules really holding
them in closely together.
The oil molecules are not
polarised in the same way.
They don't have that same
separation of charge that the
water does, and that's
why we've got
these separate layers.
But what would happen if
the oil was really hot?
Here we've got around 100
millilitres of oil.
We're going to heat this
up, and eventually
it will catch fire.
Then we're going to add some
water to the burning oil.
Now we've seen that the water
sinks underneath the oil, and
at this high temperature
it's going to
instantly turn into steam.
And then we'll see
what happens.
One millilitre of water will
produce enough steam to fill
this entire flask, which takes
up around 2000 times the
volume that the water did.
OK, I think we've got
ignition here.
If we can have the gas off.
Gas off?
Gas off.
OK?
Ready?
[EXPLOSION SOUNDS]
Well, now you can see why you
should never add water to
burning oil.
How did it look?
It was awesome.
Did it come out the top, or--
Really good.
Yes it did, for several feet,
a foot and a half--
I'm sorry, I have no idea.
Absolutely none.
But I did feel this.
It was good.